it has been four years since this
gentleman stopped by in studio
um and provided us to date the most
watched video in the history of the rich
eisen show on our youtube channel
youtube.com rich eisenshow uh he is the
star and host of adult swims the eric
andre show eric andre how are you eric
hey how you doing can you hear me i can
hear you can you hear me
beautiful yes i can loud and clear
so um loud and clear my hair is back i'm
sorry
i i filmed most of the show last year
okay so
last year you did like the vin diesel
sort of look
it kind of did you get that diesel yeah
i i
i got rid of all my body hair except my
eyebrows so i picked my head bald i
shaved my facial hair but i also did my
armpits
i narrowed my legs and i waxed my pubic
hair
okay so narrowing your legs uh by the
way i don't i don't know if i've ever
heard that used as a verb
narring your legs but i know what that
is um so
why did you do this harsh chemical that
probably
will give you cancer later in life that
makes your hair fall out
um i did it for a creative experiment
basically the previous season of my show
season four
i um i wanted to look i wanted to look
like a a
prisoner in a north korean detention
center
so i uh i lost weight i i didn't go out
in the sun i got really
as pale as i possibly could uh i
grew my fingernails out and got them all
dirty i didn't wash or brush my hair
i didn't use deodorant so i stunk i
didn't wash my suit once
and so this season as an experiment i
wanted to do
all the opposite choices that i made the
previous season so i gained weight
i got rid of all my hair i put on a ton
of cheap brute cologne and michael
jordan cologne that we found from the
90s
uh i got canned i did i did spray tan
tanning bed outdoor tan i got as brown
as i possibly could
and uh i looked i ended up looking like
um
[Music]
uh uh vin diesel had sex with cory
booker
so what's the feedback from it what's
been the feedback
first of all i have the highest rated
interview
is that true uh watch eric andre you
appeared
last on this show um in 2016 i think it
was september right chris september
2016.
um and uh yeah september 2nd you showed
up
you showed up september 2nd 2016 wearing
a t-shirt that
um was a perfect replica of the uh
tattoos of jr smith um
and oh yeah yep that do you still have
that shirt
i still haven't yeah i actually have two
copies for some reason
okay that's good yeah it's jl it's j.r
smith's
flesh it's a very weird very weird shirt
but it was
it was it looked great on you um and you
appeared here
i have a i have a i have a bootleg
rodney cycly jersey
that i was gonna but i was debating
between the jr smith flesher
and the and the knockoff little league
ronnie cycling jersey
i have not heard that name in so long is
ronnie cycling still playing for
syracuse i think he's in like his
25th year of eligibility i think so i
mean he's incredible
my him and harold miner are kind of like
my my icon baby jordan
baby jordan jordan so yes you appeared
on this show
then and what is the current total uh
chris
of that youtube video right right he is
going to go over 2.5 million very soon
wow beautiful you're a popular guy eric
people seek well i mean this is because
you give them what they want which is
a north korean prisoner one year and
then uh vin diesel the next
i mean you've got you got your finger
firmly on the pulse
you got your finger firmly on the pulse
of what your fan base wants so what has
the feedback been
of your current look what's it been um
uh you know it took a toll on my love
life
uh you know i
i did not look uh attractive i kind of
looked like a kojak drowned
that's kind of my
which by the way that's a great fantasy
team man that's a great nfl
fantasy team name kojak drowning would
be
and then let's get let's get a shot of
eric andre and use it as our avatar
we might have to change our teammates
like like if they found kelly savalas's
body at like the bottom of a pool
like that's kind of like what
i can't imagine how that would affect
you i need hair to distract from
what's going on in my face eric andre
adult swim the eric andre
show uh again uh back here on the rich
eyes and show air sunday at midnight on
adult swim and season five
premiered just uh a couple of sundays
ago so um
you said jordan colon i forgot did
jordan really have cologne or you just
made that up
jordan no michael jordan did have a
cologne uh it was very short-lived and
it
it kind of smelled like his sweat
so there wasn't like a certain drakkar
noir smell to it it really was like a
it's
um i'll be honest with you i don't
really remember
and uh but i i not only uh
put it all over my body i drank a little
bit of it just very good that all works
out that all works out for you yeah
i forgot are you a fan of any nba team
any team at all
eric do you miami heat obviously i'm
dropping clues like a maniac
i'm a die-hard heat fan what'd you think
of their run
they had a good run they had a good run
you got to give it to them man like
who would have thought they would have
gotten so far you know i think they'll
do
even better next year well eric i got to
tell you uh on our show
uh in the interim since the last time
you've been on them this time
we have we have noticed that if anybody
makes a statement
that they kind of believe but don't
really believe they
they go higher register and you just
went higher register about the miami
i'm superstitious so i don't like like
bragging and boasting about anything
until
um something's happening okay well i
mean there's something definitely
happening
much like the election i'm like doing a
rain dance over you should see me
i'm like sweating and uh doing right i i
slept like one hour last night i'm just
hitting my refresh button on my
web browser are you doing are you doomed
scrolling on your twitter feed right now
eric is that what you're doing i'm doom
scrolling
i'm prophesizing i got voodoo dolls all
laid out
i'm sweating up a storm i look like hell
um let's talk a little bit more about
your show and then i'll send you back to
your
your doom scrolling uh wednesday right
here um
you had uh along for the ride guest
stars this year
um robin givens how about yeah where did
you
when did you come across robin that's
pretty cool still
still beautiful still as beautiful as
she was
25 years ago uh i don't know i think
her i might have this wrong but i think
her son suckered her into doing the show
okay and she was not she was she was out
of sorts
i would say during the interview we had
like maggots popping out of
food and cockroaches yeah coming down
from the ceiling and
uh i brought up mike tyson which he did
not appreciate
and uh it got tense it was
there's deaf awkward pause in your
interview with robin gibbons is that
what you're saying
there was several several i'd say
several did she
i mean how do you handle a situation
like that do you enjoy the awkwardness
you you
you relish i'm mining
for awkwardness i am a truffle pig
sniffing the soil mining for awkwardness
i guess i'm kind of the opposite i i i i
try to avoid those moments in interviews
quite honestly yes well you
you are a classy competent
interviewer i am trying i am i i set my
career out trying to be the worst
interviewer of all time
uh and hopefully i'm succeeding what did
you just say in my ear chris
oh what's the most awkward one that
you've had over the years
oh lauren conrad walked out during an
interview lauren conrad walked out
ti the rapper walked out uh robin
gibbons wasn't pleased we had blake
griffin on this year he was like
but griffin goes that was so
nerve-wracking he goes i was more
nervous
during your interview than uh during a
playoff game
now that's because you know he's got a
reputation and he doesn't want to have
something on
uh you know sitting out there forever
more you know what i mean i guess
but he's got a huge sense of humor
though so you could pretty much going
into direction with him
yeah i mean we were lighting them up
i mean we were hitting them we were
getting at them from all angles i mean
we were torturing the guy
so t.i walked out he was t i walked out
yeah there was a lot of full frontal
male nudity during his
uh interview that he didn't really
appreciate
you know not his humor oh this is fair
now again that's part of the way i try
to avoid
awkwardness here on the rich eisen show
is not to have that part of the
interview process
you know yeah yeah i have a different
tactic
what's the difference between oh my gosh
uh who do you want in your show that you
haven't had eric
uh
i don't know come on there's gotta be
somebody get bill
we're trying to get bill cosby on this
season but that was tense
looking at this dozen non-stewards
charles manson we were like like
coordinating like
reaching out and emailing the prison
that he was at he was still alive at the
time
and uh yeah we never get charles man so
was it a logistical problem for cosby or
he just refused your
your your your uh uh we did not get a
response
do you think he looked up your work do
you think that could be it
i think he researched it let me see what
eric andre is about oh wait a minute
there's full frontal male nudity and
maggots
i don't i don't think he has access to
research
uh materials right now
but uh yeah i don't know
uh dream guests uh come on oprah would
be nice
i mean are we shooting for the stars
here yes of course that's
well yeah i'm not gonna hold you to it
but i mean
oprah would be quite an
oprah appearance on the eric andre show
might break every possible record
i think and the internet right that's
right that's right
all right eric i appreciate the time
let's not do it once every four years
like the election okay it's
2016 and 2020 all right um
let's at least let's make it let's
midterm it at the very least okay
let's do it sounds good you take care of
yourself
that's eric andre you go that's eric
andre at eric andre on twitter
we cannot mention his instagram title
on the show as a matter of fact that was
a specific decision we made
wait really well it's his let's just put
it this way it's his first look up his
life i haven't i i don't look up his
instagram
let's just say it's his first name and
his last name and then the middle is a
word that
is one that you cannot say on television
so think about it
and then you'll have it oh no let's see
the photo from his previous appearance
there it is
that is exactly the body art
of j.r smith and you just looked up his
name yeah that's right it's a specific
name it's funny that was available it
was
probably somebody was squatting on that
yeah nobody was squatting he went to go
daddy and got it
maybe that's why he had to put that word
in the middle because someone already
had eric andre
some people put an underscore yeah right
or something somebody put a dot
i just had to hashtag him
that word let me see if that's available
for you rich
you have never said hey when this guest
is coming on
let's use maggots never once no no no no
no
no no no no never had the walk off so
robin gibbon shows up
because her son said do it and she
didn't see it coming huh
she didn't see it coming rich if you
want a um
uh a bat account on uh instagram
is available and it's available who knew
it wouldn't really be a bad account if
it's still his name though right
hey commissioner do you want to follow
me on instagram
sure rich what's your name
[Laughter]
hey rg1 um i don't know if you're on
instagram i know you're at nfl
commission on twitter you uh
would you mind following me on instagram
here's my address
at rich ethanol here's my ghost account
my ghost account
yeah you know people saying you know
you ever do ever you ever hover about
hit and send on on
uh on your tweets and of course you know
there are times you have to
you always always have to think twice
three times four times before hitting
that
thumb on your send button and one of the
people i think about all the time is
what would roger think
about what you're tweeting yes of course
he's my boss he's the boss he's my boy
blue
can i say that you're my boy